- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is Put
Things in Perspective.
Over to you, Jean-Claude Biver.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning.
- When you have a down time,
like if something didn't
work the way you want.
- Yes.
- What do you do to get
back on that positiveness?
- I talk to the mountain.
I have mountain next to my home
that is called Rochers de Naye.
It goes up to two.
It's very low.
It goes up to 2,004 or 2,005 meters.
Or I talk to the Dents du Midi,
which is 4,000 meters, which
is a little bit further away
from my home, which I see every morning.
I see those two mountains,
and I say to these two mountains,
mountains, I have a problem,
but when I look at you,
you are 37 million old.
(laughs)
And I'm a little guy.
- You seem to be okay.
- I'm a little guy here.
- And strong and tough.
- We have a little problem.
Can you help me?
And the will say, come on.
(laughs)
Look, what we have already
seen in so many years.
(laughs)
Your problem is a nano problem.
Come on.
Get up.
- Just get up. Do it.
- That's it.
- Entrepreneurs do stupid things
when they lose perspective.
People do stupid things
You make decisions that are
not in the best interest
of your long-term self,
of the best version
of yourself cause you're so
clouded by what's happening
in the moment, and you
can't step out above.
I may be the wrong target for this one.
I have a hard time with this message
mostly because I don't get lost that much
in the day to day.
I don't lose perspective that much.
I think it's just more my personality.
I don't get too highs with the highs,
and I don't get too low with the lows.
I'm always constantly on stream, like,
here's what we're trying to do.
Okay, if there's a problem, great.
Let's problem solve it, but
a problem in my business
doesn't have to have a major
impact, for the most part,
on how I feel about myself.
And so we can get back on it.
There's been maybe five days in my life
where I've just been
so down or out or crazy
that I lost perspective in
what I was trying to do.
I think about when the
hardest day of my life
when I told my business
partner that I quit.
And it was just kind of in the moment,
frustrated, feeling out of control,
feeling like I had no value to give,
feeling so worthless that
I made a rash decision
telling him that I quit.
I didn't have the perspective.
When I got up the next day,
and I went back to work,
I just realized I had to
find a different way to stay.
And I realized it was still something
that I really cared about,
and so I don't really do
a lot of things where I lose perspective.
But I can understand for
others how it can be,
I'm the weird one.
I'm the crazy one.
I realize that's not most people.
I think one thing though
that can definitely help is gratitude.
I think when you are grateful
for the things in your life,
you easily gain more perspective.
It's something that I have a
daily routine of and have had
for years because it also
just makes me feel good.
If you think about how fortunate you are
even just to be watching this video,
to have internet, to
have a house, to be fed,
to live in an age where you have access
to people who've done
things that you want to do
and can learn from where 10 years ago,
even, this didn't exist.
Forget about what your grandparents
or great-grandparents had access to.
For the air that you get to breathe,
you know, for the people in your life,
for you just being a human
being instead of an ant,
you know, like, there's so many things
you can be grateful for.
And just thinking about those things
can make your problems seem a lot smaller,
a lot less significant,
a lot less important,
and that will allow you to then go off
and do the right thing.
So I would encourage you
if you ever feel like life
is spiraling out of control,
one, try not to make
any decisions when that's happening.
Try not to make an important life decision
by reacting quickly to something.
Just hold your tongue, and sleep on it.
And then, two, just try to think about
what you can be grateful for.
What is good in your life?
There may be a lot that you
feel is terrible in your life,
but compare it to most of the world.
You've got it pretty good.
And it's really hard to
be depressed and angry
and vengeful and hateful and spiteful.
It's hard to hold those emotions
at the same time as being grateful.
And so if you can focus on your gratitude,
and what you are really thankful for,
they can help give you the perspective
you need to make the
best decisions for you.
So the question of the day today is,
this is what I do every day.
I'm curious.
Three things that you are grateful for.
Leave it down in the comments below.
Super curious to find out,
and we will join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Christian.
Christian, thank you
so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Hey, Believe Nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it,
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- My question is, I'm entrepreneur.
It's very great, but
not all days are great
in a company, so what
are your tips and trick
for, you know, tough days?
- I think there's massive
confusion around entrepreneurship.
Entrepreneurship sucks.
I mean, it's lonely.
It's high-risk.
I mean, I can't live without it,
but it's like a bad boyfriend, right,
or girlfriend, right, like
there's a ton of bad days being
an entrepreneur, not to mention 98%
of entrepreneurial
ventures are going to fail,
so there's going to be a
really bad in your future.
(audience laughs)
- You know, hopefully, not for you.
Or any of you.
You know, for me, I don't, I think it's
a very personal question.
I think it's how you're wired.
I'm so all-in entrepreneur.
I prefer the pain.
I think one of the reasons
I love the Jets so much
is cause they bring me so much pain.
You know, I love the climb.
To me, the setback is exciting.
I love when something goes wrong.
It's where I shine the most.
But that's not for everybody, right?
I mean, it can be very difficult,
and when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and
all the other things,
it can get real nasty.
To me, the way I handle things even
in the few rare days
when I really struggle,
I take a real step back and make pretend
that somebody called me and told me
that my mother or daughter were killed.
And I know that's very dark.
I apologize, but it's really what I do.
I literally am able to, at my deepest
most struggling moment within business,
take a step back and remind myself
I could make a drillion dollars tomorrow
on Bitcoin, and if something bad happened
to the people I love the most
then it wold mean nothing.
And it very consistently
rewires me very quickly.
I just put business in perspective.
At the end of the day,
you know, it's money.
For me, it's not really money.
It's my legacy, so I get
hurt by it a little bit more,
but yeah, you know, I
put it in perspective.
It's money, and you know what?
Up until I had a daughter,
even while I was married,
up until when I had Mischa four years ago,
I secretly wanted to lose all my money.
I had this weird, twisted, dark fantasy
of losing everything just to rise again
like a phoenix and remind you.
(audience laughs)
- You, I mean, obviously, you
can't come on a show like this
without mention of the
wanking in the toilet thing.
(laughs)
- Which one, in the toilet thing?
Which one?
- The arresting.
- Oh, of course.
- [Graham] That one.
The one we've heard about.
- That one.
The time I got caught, you mean.
- Yeah, that one.
(audience laughs)
Possibly it's the last time.
(audience applauds)
And see, this is the thing.
This is the thing that amazes me.
The way you talk about
it is your fantastic
sort of unapologetic about it.
And you didn't go into hiding.
You didn't, you know, sort of go,
you know, draw the curtains.
Was it the next night you were out
in a restaurant in LA having dinner?
- Absolutely.
What's to apologize for?
You know, I'm a gay man.
At the time, I was like 36-years-old.
Can I be, if I'm perfectly honest,
if I'm perfectly, perfectly honest,
outside of my career, I've
had a terrible run of luck
that started about 10 years ago.
I've watched a partner die.
I've watched my mother die.
I went, just after that, I
went to see a back surgeon
who told that if I didn't
have two vertebrae removed
within the next six months to a year
that I could be paralyzed,
so you just learn
to have a different perspective.
I don't give a toss if
people have a real problem
with me, you know, having--
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
I have a different perspective on life.
I've lost a lot of great things,
but I still have a lot
of incredible things.
And the press doesn't
really enter into it.
- Do you feel underrated as a rapper?
- Not as of lately, which is crazy.
For a long time, man,
for years, I was pissed,
so a song on the album called Buried Alive
is about that exact thing.
You know, it's about,
like, me kind of goin'
how come he gets the so and so cosign
or how come he gets that
or how come they get that?
I can tour the world.
I can sell out shows.
I got fans.
I got this.
What the, man, like being angry.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- You know, I had a friend tell me.
She basically said, those same people
who have the cosigns and have the this
and have the looks, are the
same people who are going,
how come I ain't fans like this then?
How come I can't tour on my own?
How come I can't this?
Like, what the, so it kind of put things
into perspective for me and let me go,
okay, I don't have it yet,
but if I keep fighting
and I keep working hard and I keep staying
on this path, it's going to happen.
You know, and as of late,
within the last few months,
man, just from, you know,
like, releasing the singles
and the music videos and
like, this solid body of work,
I've truly began to get what I deserve.